er liebe sogar daran und soldaten
geschätzte bedienstete des
verteidigungsministeriums des
österreichischen bundesheeres
aber wie sie wissen ist meine
amtsführung aus meiner sicht leider sehr
früh zu ende gegangen und ich möchte
trotzdem die gelegenheit nutzen will ich
sehr herzlich bei ihnen zu bedanken zu
bedanken für das was sie tagtäglich in
ihrer dienste richtung für die
sicherheit österreichs leisten
ganz gleich ob im auslandseinsatz ganz
gleich ob im einsatz
an der grünen grenze oder immer dann
wenn die österreicher in österreich
schutz und hilfe benötigen
die letzten monate waren für mich die
schönsten monate meines beruflichen
lebens
vieles ist gelungen vieles hätte noch
passieren soll und vieles ist doch
leider offen geblieben ich bin aber
davon überzeugt dass er mein nachfolger
auch in diesem sinne wie es das
regierungsprogramm vorsieht
weiterarbeiten wird dass er die reform
an die eingeleitet wurden weiter
fortsetzt
dass er dafür sorgt dass das bundesheer
ein starkes bundesheer ist und dass er
auch das duo sich versucht habe nämlich
ihnen meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren größte wertschätzung
entgegenzubringen
ich bedanke mich nochmals bei ihnen für
alles was sie für österreich leisten uns
tun
ich bedanke mich für das was sie für das
bundesheer leisten und damit auch für
die bürgerinnen und bürger unserer
wunderschönen heimat alles liebe
herzlichen dank mit kameradschaftlichen
grüßen ihr mario kunasek